clark county school district students go
back to class tomorrow amid this surge
in coronavirus cases but thousands of
other u.s schools have delayed the
return of in-class learning the oklahoma
joining us now live in the newsroom to
talk about the safety measures that ccsd
has in place and that plan to return to
class bianca
good morning so the clark county school
district is set to resume in-person
class this week the district recognizes
the increase in cases and says they will
continue strict cleaning protocols so
the district shared their protocols with
us to keep students safe they said
they're using the r0 arc uvc system in
every campus in the district and every
campus has one so this helps destroy 99
percent of surface and airborne
pathogens in less than seven minutes
without the use of harmful chemicals and
there's also cleaning throughout the day
along with vacuuming again around each
campus and of course restroom cleaning
very important they use a germicidal
spray on all the surfaces and
from the start in august of this school
year there have been just over 1 000
positive coveted cases that's among
students and staff and of course this
month we're only a couple of days in
there have been two reported cases so
coming up in the next half hour i'm
going to share insight from the
pediatrician on how to handle both
covert flu and cold season because
remember there's some other stuff going
around in our valley as well not just
coven and so that's coming up in the
next half hour bianca holman live local
now